ساذهب الان الى فوزي المرضي والد الطبيبه
الاء التي راحت ضحيه رصاصه طائشه عبر
نافذه منزلها اهلا بك استاذ فوزي والبقاء
لله هل يمكن ان تخبرنا ماذا حصل بالضبط
الحمد لله
سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
حقيقه
في المستشفى في الحاره
بمصر الاحياء
وصلت البيت مبسوطه جدا مرتاحه يعطيني في
الموضوع
من الناس وصلنا
الفنجان قهوه لانه انا فاطر
لما طلعت
في الصالون هناك
مشيت امه قالت
الستاره بتاعه الشباك
مختلف القزاز
فتحت الجزاء كانت وراء امه طوالي يا طلقه
طوال كثره القزاز ضربت امها في الاول في
الفك الايمن حقها شالت اللحم بتاع الفجر
ضرباتها في بتاعتها ومشط ضربه البت في
قلبها
مباشره وقعت
متوفيه توفى الطوال في الحال
فوزي اين انتم تعيشون اين كانت تتركز هذه
الاشتباكات حتى الرصاصه باي منطقه انتم
المناطق القرن الضرب كان موجود في منطقه
كرري انا كنت ساكن في المناره ساكن في
الطائره الاول
الطابق الاول في حي المناره
اين كانت تعمل اين كانت تعمل الاء في اي
مستشفى
وهل كانت هناك هل كانت هناك ايضا اشتباكات
حول هذه المستشفى
لكن كان في الشارع فيه
يعني الشارع فاضي الناس كلها اختفت في
بيوتها فدخلت خوف على اساس
العربيه
بوسط الاحياء جابوا
وصلت ما اخذت خمس دقائق
هل تمكنتم هل كان هناك من صعوبه لنقلها
الى المستشفى عندما اصيبت الراحله الاء
والله
الاهتمام كان ضربت ضربه شديدا
ووقعت برضه كانت لفردا
ولدك شان الامور واولاد الناس في العماره
المرحومه على اساس
شالوها في المستشفى في المستشفى
طلبت منه انه موافق
التلفون ضربت له اخواننا
الاجراءات بتاعه شهاده الوفاء ودخل
الثلاجه عندهم لانه كان الموقف صعب جدا في
المنطقه بتاعه المغاري
شديد جدا
في المشرحه الى
ثاني يوم الصباح
الساعه تسعه صباحا واديناها في مقابل احمد
النيل
هنالك الحمد لله والشكر لله
نحن
من النار ان شاء الله
سيد فوزي هل الان حيث وانتم هل هناك
اشتباكات هل هناك
قصف حولكم مازال حتى الان
انا غادرت الاعمار النهائي يعني
الابيض
العائله الكبير
وزوجتي الان في المستشفى
انتظر لها عمليه بكره
واخبرنا الحقيقه واحنا بعض الاخوان ولكن
والدتها هل هل حالتها
افضل الان
كانت حاله متاخره شويه لكن الان استغربت
قبيله تكلمت معاي على اساس انه انا في
سمعت خبر انه توفت قلت لها
بتكفي العنايه المكثفه وحالتها حيه في
المستشفى ابتعد
في المستشفى عملياته قريبين من بعض لكن
ما بتقدر تتكلم معكم ما بقدر انا يعني
كذبت على لكن حفاظا عليها لانها هي في
حاله
يعني حالتها كويسه كابتن فوزي
غير الاء يعني شو عندك اولاد
المهندس
مدثر
واحمد موجود هو كان في الامارات العربيه
موجود معنا
لكن كانت عندي
ما تغلى على الله اطلاق الله يخلي لك
اياهن كابتن حضرتك ايضا يعني كابتن فريق
الهلال السوداني
وطبعا يعني الرياضه هي من من ابرز الامور
واكثر الامور التي تجعل الناس
تكون موحده حول محبه فريق معين وحول
محبه ايضا لاي منتخب في البلاد
كم الامر صعب الان عندما ترى السودان بهذه
الحاله وبهذا الاقتتال الداخلي
والله يا استاذه انا لاول مره
حياته في السودان وكان في مظاهرات وكان في
لكن الحصل ده حصل
صعب جدا جدا جدا جدا يعني نحن في المناطق
في المنطقه اللي عايشين فيها نحن قريبين
من السلاح المهندسين من السلاح الطبي من
كبر النيل الابيض احنا عايشين في هلا لانه
في
التبادل بتاع الرصاص والتبادل بتاع
المدافع
ونحن عايشين والله السودان حاله
خرطوم والحاره